the  [Music]  partnership between our countries is  unique and enduring and of course it's  bigger than any two individuals but I'm  proud to have stewardship of it at the  moment and as you said yeah well as you  said the United States is that our  biggest trading partner closer security  partner and I'm glad to see that  partnership in action doing good whether  it's standing up to and I agree with  your words barbaric activity by Russia  in Ukraine but also tackling climate  change stabilizing the global economy  our values were alive our interests are  aligned and as much good that we can do  working together I look forward to all  this stuff I'm looking forward to it